what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals man I'm gonna tell you
something okay look here's the thing man
this store Sansa dude I love this so
much this this has one of the greatest
moments ever in a Marvel comic story
it's absolutely mind-blowing so check
this out in the last video that we did
we basically covered this whole thing
where in order to Stave off their
destruction at the hands of the eternals
because they were quite readily losing
that you basically had Tony Stark and
you had some of the eternals who didn't
Ally with Druid who's trying to wipe out
pretty much all the X-Men right he's the
leader of the eternals that they
reactivated the progenitor Celestial
right he's all Frankenstein kind of
hodgepodge from different pieces but as
soon as the progenitor Celestial
manifested right as soon as he showed up
he was just like let the conflict end
and I'm judging everybody on this planet
I'm judging you individually and I will
judge you as a collective if I judge in
favor of you you will be able to
continue your existence on Earth if I
judge against you I will kill everybody
here right I will eradicate all life on
this planet and it's game over Act
accordingly so what happens here and
this is one of the coolest things right
what happens here is you basically have
the frigiditor celestial analyzing
everybody here right looking over every
single person and the first person he
hones in on is Captain America right he
literally says once more Captain America
seeks to inspire he thinks himself a
leader one who sets the drum beat for
the world I will judge him first and so
he basically appears or at least kind of
manifests this sort of perfect looking
Captain America type thing and says you
are a dream of a better country right
that's literally what you represent a
better America you have tried to inspire
it for a century this country is the
world leader and the world is what it is
it is worse every single day you Captain
America have failed Captain America
initially rejects this and is like we're
not playing this game right we're not
doing the game with this stupid thing
we're basically blowing off all of this
and so in the end he's like we need to
figure out how it is that we're
basically going to satisfy the Judgment
of this Celestial on a broader scale now
that's one of the cool elements of
Captain America very rarely does Steve
Rogers ever succumb to like mind games
and Shadow tricks right that almost
never works on Steve Rogers not because
he's immune to it right like a telepath
could screw up the mind of Steve Rogers
with relative ease right what makes
Steve Rogers so cool is that he has this
level of fortitude and this level of
leadership that is respected by
everybody in pretty much the entirety of
the Marvel Universe but the thing about
this is we basically transition over to
the exclusion zone now remember the
exclusion zone is basically where
eternals are resurrected when they die
or it's Werther held prisoner
specifically we have Druid who again is
the leader of the eternals which is
basically fractured so you've got Druid
who's leading a group of eternals and
pretty much most of the Eternal Empire
that wants to destroy the mutant
population because their quote unquote
excess deviation remember that's one of
the big things the story's doing is it's
establishing that mutants didn't just
arbitrarily come into existence they're
basically humans that have a deviant
Gene and have just developed Powers as a
result of that but but druick is
literally talking here to Uranus and
Uranus wants to be set free now remember
in the last few videos that we did we
saw how powerful Uranus was he showed up
to Mars which is a settlement that has
mutants on it but not just any mutants
they're all Omega Level mutants right
the most powerful of the mutant race and
he killed like 98 of them in one hour
that's how powerful that guy is right
he's just on a whole new level of
strength it's kind of crazy what we end
up having in this conversation is of
course Uranus who says okay the
celestials already judged Captain
America and found him to be a failure so
now the question is how long before it
judges everybody else and in reality
it's kind of a Race Against Time here
because the perception of Druid and
those eternals who were on his side is
that our mission as eternals is to
correct quote unquote excess deviation
which only ever comes in two forms
either it's deviants who have like
basically mutated further and they have
to be destroyed they become deviants
that basically kill other deviants and
even eternals or it's humor comments
with a deviant Gene that had developed
Powers I.E mutants and the fact that
he's like we haven't killed basically
every mutant on Earth that's the failure
of our Charter that's why it will judge
against us and so his stance is we have
to eradicate them as fast as possible
now where you do have the druig-led
eternals which are like we have to kill
basically all the mutants on Earth if we
possibly can and then you've got those
eternals that are working against him
Tony Stark basically working alongside
the eternals that stand on the side of
the X-Men along with basically Mr
Sinister who's a mutant that they
kidnapped ultimately Tony Stark's
approaching this from the perspective of
like how do we shut down that Celestial
now one of the things you remember here
is Tony Stark has experience with this
don't forget the god killer honor right
the god killer armor was a suit of armor
who literally was just kind of a giant
robot that was developed by the
aspirants when they originally went to
war with the celestials at the beginning
of all of creation that 25
000 foot tall piece of metal that was
controlled by Tony Stark he's also
created armors that allow him to tap
into Celestial energy right to basically
control a Celestial so he's well aware
of like how to deactivate these things
the problem is even those eternals who
were on the side of the X-Men are like
no because the reality of this is the
eternals see the celestials as like
their prophesized beings they don't
really agree with what this Celestial is
doing but they believe the best way to
overcome the Judgment of Earth is to
basically unify the world not to destroy
the celestial itself but the other part
of this is their program remember
eternals were created by celestials and
the result of this is that the
programming of the eternals is that if a
Celestial is on Earth and if it is in
danger they have to respond it'll
override their conscious thoughts
they'll literally just become robots
basically that have to run through and
save a Celestial and Destroy whatever
threat is standing against them and
that's kind of where you have these two
groups at odds Tony Stark thinks the
best possible thing is to destroy it
these eternals that are on the side of
the Avengers and the X-Men just refuse
to let that happen and so what you end
up doing is again jumping back to
krakowa where you have the X-Men
basically the most powerful mutants on
Earth who were standing against the hex
now remember one of the things that had
happened here in this story this whole
Avengers X-Men Eternal story is it
basically removed the eternals from just
being a handful of people who live on
earth and sometimes they get involved in
stuff and instead it turned them into a
whole society and one of the things that
we learned is that the hex are basically
the foot soldiers right they're like the
Special Forces guys of the eternals
they're enormous they're as big as
skyscrapers but like they're the ones
the eternals dispatch if things get
really really bad they have to go to war
and basically just run over some enemy
with overwhelming force and that's what
they have to do with krakowa because
some of the most powerful beings in
existence in the mutant population and
even just at all in Marvel Comics are in
krakowa so they have to approach
accordingly and so for the most part the
X-Men are literally fending off as best
they can and you even have Destiny who
can kind of see the future depending on
how far out she's looking who basically
meets with Emma Frost one of the most
powerful telepaths on Earth and is like
we need to basically have some kind of a
meeting but the reality here is Emma
Frost was like I mean we can but just
keep in mind like while we're
telepathically communicating we're also
fighting out here on the battlefield
Destiny basically says okay like I've
looked through the various options and
the only way for us to really come out
on top here is to launch a strike force
against the celestial because I've seen
what happens with this battle and if we
continue fighting like this we will lose
because the reality here is that every
time a mutant dies sure we can resurrect
ourselves but we basically have to be
fed information on what happened which
is secondary knowledge when an eternal
dies and they're resurrected by the
great machine they remember everything
right they remember every single thing
the experiences not only that they learn
they correct and they learn which means
they are going to get the upper hand on
us at some point in time this battle
cannot keep going on or they will kill
us all so launching this Strike Force is
the only way to do it now initially some
of them are kind of against it they're
like no no no we should not do that like
we should not launch a strike force and
try to destroy a Celestial because
because what if it doesn't work like
what if we what if we try to blow up a
Celestial and it doesn't work he's gonna
eradicate us all but he's gonna kill us
all just for pissing him off and that's
exactly the the real concern to have
here but the other part of this is that
some of the mutants there are like but
it's so risk worth taking it's one worth
doing and so what you end up having is
also Emma Frost who says yes but we also
have a third option right here on
krakowa we've been Waging War or
fighting against the eternals and we can
only fight for so long but there is a
force out there that we have not tapped
into yet that will Ally themselves to
our cause and that's when we transition
over to the krakowan gates now remember
only those who have a mutant Gene can
pass through the cocrowing gates and if
there were any doubt in Marvel Comics as
to whether or not mutants are a genetic
offshoot of the deviants this confirms
it this solidifies that it's an absolute
truth because the other force that Emma
Frost was referring to are the deviants
themselves now one of the things to keep
in mind is that deviants are as powerful
as eternals under any normal
circumstance and depending on what
deviant you're talking about some of
them are more powerful than the eternals
so literally what you have is Emma Frost
who has basically made Bargains with a
deviance and an entire Army of deviants
come swollen to give you guys
perspective here remember at the end of
Avengers end game when you had like just
what was left of the Avengers facing off
against like the entire Army of Thanos
and then all the portals start opening
up and basically every superhero that
we've ever seen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe up to that point all emerges at
the same time that's this that's
basically what's going on here and so
what this does is it drastically evens
the odds but even then the prophecy of
Destiny remains we cannot keep this
battle going forever we will inevitably
lose and so what this does is it
switches back over to Tony Stark and the
eternals who are all talking and Tony
Stark is adamant about this idea right
like we have to find a way to destroy
the celestial but the eternals simply
won't won't let him and in truth there's
not really any thing Tony Stark can do
to overcome the power of the eternals
right they're just way too capable for
him but in the midst of all this
discussion that's going on Mr Sinister
ever the manipulator and the schemer
ends up going over to one of the
computer panels and basically exposes a
node for Celestial for the celestial
itself that if it's attacked with enough
energy will blow the whole thing up the
big concern here is if they do that what
kind of collateral damage are they
looking at like say for example they
detonate this Celestial say for example
this Celestial does get blown up by some
capacity millions of people in the
immediate vicinity will die but the
stance of Mr Sinister and even Tony
Stark to a degree is yes but future
billions will live right this is just
classic utilitarianism the needs of the
many outweigh the needs of the few
there's no argument about that there's
no discussion about that right like
that's just the way that it has to go
now again while Sinister is doing that
you actually end up having the eternals
realizing that there's a secondary
breach that's taken place here that
basically there's infiltrators some kind
kind of a strike team has arrived to
their location and is infiltrating the
celestial and that's basically because
of what's going on here because the the
celestial itself is now in immediate
danger by way of the actions of Mr
Sinister and the fact that Wolverine and
Jean Gray and those guys have arrived as
a strike force the programming takes
over and immediately the eternals turn
on the X-Men right those who were on the
scene and immediately attack them all
right like literally just it's like this
massive battle that takes place between
all of them right these most powerful
mutants that exist in Marvel Comics
alongside they are facing off against
these eternals the war is Extreme and it
is Harsh and that's the crazy thing at
the end of the day the X-Men and kind of
a last-ditch effort are able to pull off
the attack and they destroy the
celestial which lets off this just
colossal atomic explosion that
eradicates millions of people and then
it ends then it stops and then suddenly
they realize the celestial's not gone
the celestial is there intact and that's
when Jean Gray comes to the realization
none of that actually happened there was
no colossal battle there was no major
war they were literally just shown by
this Celestial what would have happened
had they pulled off that attack this is
a strike against them because what it
means is that the population of Earth
would rather have destroyed millions of
people than find some peaceful
resolution to their conflict and so the
celestial doesn't necessarily use that
as a sign of judgment and say I judge
against the entirety of the human race
but what it does do is it literally says
okay it communicates with the entirety
of the world and it says everybody on
Earth you need to know this right I have
shown you every single person on the
face of the planet I have shown you what
this explosion would look like and I've
shown you the damage that it would do
you need to know that the people on this
earth right the the superheroes that
stand before you that they see
themselves as being gods above judgment
now all of you see that they are
mistaken your day ticks away you've got
24 hours to prove yourself remember that
was a statement that Celestial made you
have 24 hours to prove to me that you're
a race worth saving your day takes away
justify yourself that's a really really
important thing to understand because to
give you guys perspective here Jean Gray
is an immensely powerful telepath right
on a universal scale and the fact that a
Celestial was able to just trick her and
every other telepath on earth into
believing that what they were seeing was
real is a testament to its level of
power that's why I say this is the most
powerful Celestial to ever exist because
it's a combination of a multitude of
other celestials and so what it does is
it presents this scenario kind of
talking to us more as the reader than
anything else that it says more
judgments right thumbs down for the
woman of diamond for Emma Frost right
she's one that probably deserves a
thumbs down she's kind of a prick uh
thumbs up for the Deviant warlord right
thumbs down for the woman who walks
between Futures and the woman who walks
beside her right Destiny and her lover
Mystique that is going through each of
these individual people and is judging
in favor of them or against them now the
reality of this is that when it says I
will judge you individually and then I
will judge you as a collective what this
seems to to indicate is that each person
is basically a tally thumbs up thumbs
down if there are more thumbs Downs
across the entire spectrum of the human
race and there are thumbs up everybody
gets destroyed right if there's more
strikes Against Humanity than for
Humanity or if there are more evil
people in the world than good people the
world will end if not the world will be
allowed to continue on and so what you
have is this really really cool moment
where you basically have this discussion
where it's like okay they communicate
with Captain America and what Captain
America says is look guys like this
whole thing of us Waging War against
each other this is not gonna work if we
keep on doing this and we keep on
fighting each other that's going to do
nothing but cause problems what we need
is someone who can unify the world what
we need is someone who can bring the
world together Sun Sun he's like what we
need is somebody that can unify the war
right God I love this moment so much and
so what this does is it switches over to
Cersei now Cersei has this idea she ends
up getting with Jack Ablaze I remember
Jack Ablaze is an eternal who's an
assassin but knows how to get in and out
of places that people aren't normally
supposed to get in and out of what he
does is basically sneak her into the
exclusion Zone into the eternals prison
and Resurrection chamber right kind of
serving both purposes and as they get in
there there's this kind of conversation
where she's like yes like we need
somebody who's going to unify the
entirety of the Earth's population God
I'm so excited about this so what they
do is they make their way to a vault and
when this person is like who's there
Cersei responds and says we're here to
break you out I think we're in terrible
trouble and I think you can help someone
to get the world singing from the same
him sheep now I know this is eternal's
business but some of us have never been
just eternals and I thought that perhaps
it's time for a little of the old
Avengers to assemble and what we end up
finding out is the person she's talking
to is Eros also known as Star Fox for
those of you guys who don't know why
this guy is so important Eros has the
ability to manipulate the emotional
states of people what Eros could do if
it's powers are pushed to the Limit what
he could do is literally unify the
entire world even if it's against their
will the question you have to ask here
is is this the final straw because if
Eros comes along and he manipulates the
world into experiencing a sense of
Harmony and unification will the
celestial see through it will he know
it's an illusion or will they end up
taking the powers of Eros and using it
on a Celestial which begs the question
can he even do that but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
peace